welcome back to cbs this morning covet
apparently not stopping people who want
to get home to see loved ones there
that's a scene from the airport
until recently this was a rare scene at
airports but in 2020 but long lines
they've returned
as millions of people are going away for
thanksgiving despite the surging
coronavirus cases
tsa workers screened more than 3 million
people between friday and sunday and
that is their busiest three-day stretch
since march at the same time tens of
thousands of airline
employees are still out of work chris
van cleave learned how some of them are
doing
good morning to you chris what did they
say to you
well good morning gail they are holding
on to hope and
really hoping that between with the
trump administration says
in its support for a stimulus democrats
in the house support for a stimulus
that something can get done to bring
them some help
so far that hasn't happened united's
chairman wrote an
impassioned open letter to other
businesses pleading with them
to hire furloughed airline workers but
when we talk to some of the thousands of
folks who have been without a job now
for over a month
they're starting to get really worried
that help isn't coming
what transition you want to make in that
field i would like to still work around
customer base driven jobs
flight attendant terry evans is job
hunting he took
unpaid leave early in the pandemic and
then got furloughed along with nearly 35
000 others when the government's payroll
support program expired at the end of
september
he hasn't had a paycheck since march how
is the job market right now
it kind of has its up days and its down
days but more down than up
for me i'm feeling like it's a big huge
circle i'm applying every day
employment centers in several northern
virginia communities just launched a
rapid response program to help airline
and airport workers who have lost jobs
due to the pandemic
offering free in-person and virtual
resources like resume writing
and networking michael briscoe is an
employment and training specialist
are there jobs out there that'll pay
their bills so that's where the
challenge comes in there are
opportunities out there but you have to
be prepared for those opportunities
with congress unable to agree on a
second coveted relief package
cbs news estimates more than 90 thousand
airline workers have lost their jobs
through furloughs layoffs or by taking
exit packages
nearly 84 thousand others have taken
unpaid leave
thousands more have experienced pay cuts
i'm just really nervous
i'm really scared about where my health
will lie we met denishia mccluskey just
before she was furloughed still holding
out hope
congress would act they didn't her
crohn's disease once nearly killed her
and requires regular costly infusions
now she's just weeks away from losing
her health insurance
i want to be able to continue the
treatment because it's been working
and i want to be able to continue to
live what to me would be deemed a
healthy
lifestyle and i'm scared of that being
ripped
right away from me daryl aaron and his
wife both got furloughed and then days
later
had their first child they've now got a
newborn baby girl
but no jobs i need to make sure that
she's taken care of we're making ends
meet right now but it's going to be
tight if we don't have some income in
the near future
back at the career center terry evans
moved in with family to save money while
he job hunts
honestly this can't go on for much
longer because bills never stop
we need health insurance we need to live
airlines have renewed their push with
congress last week the ceos
told lawmakers that they need additional
aid citing the spike in coronavirus
cases and the increase in cancellations
they fear could be
devastating once the holidays pass also
they say they need to have more people
on staff so they can be nimble to help
with vaccine distribution
anthony wow 90 000 airline workers out
of work really hope these people get
some
so i hope they find work or get work or
get some help chris thank you very much